[Musique]
autrefois nombre d'alsaciens apprenait
le français en arrivant à l'école
aujourd'hui pour ces jeunes celle
inverse on parle français à la maison et
alsaciens d'hirondelles de l'école jean
petit à lingolsheim ici trois niveaux de
maternelle suivre une scolarité en
immersion à parts égales entre langues
régionales et allemands en cp ses
enfants suivront les cours en allemand
puis à parts égales entre français et
allemands à partir du ce1
l'école est porté par l'association abcm
qui entend permettre l'enseignement
bilingue en langue régionale 3 langues
quelques années rien de compliqué pour
le jeune cerveau ce qui nous demanderait
un travail acharné et pour les
tout-petits d'une facilité déconcertante
alors ils sont tout petits se sont
effectivement deux nouvelles langues
la plupart ne les ont pas entendu la
façon dont nous nous instruisons les
enfants en fait va être de façon
naturelle comme à la maison lorsqu'on
apprend le français avec tout le
quotidien en fait qu on apprend en
français avec les enfants nous aussi
tout le quotidien on le fait en allemand
ou en alsacien donc les activités les
plaisirs les jeux tout se fait donc en
allemand et en alsacien
c'est justement là j'ai envie de dire
vraiment la réussite pour ces enfants là
parce que ça va être appris de façon
naturelle c'est vraiment une langue de
communication et c'est pas comme nous
quand on a appris à partir de la sixième
ou là on va être que dans la grammaire
et dans l'orthographe on va vraiment
utiliser cette langue là dans le
quotidien
à partir des années 90 nombre
d'associations locales oeuvre à
développer l'enseignement bilingue à ce
moment-là pratique de l'alsatia est en
net repli dans les jeunes générations
transformant de fait le rhin en
frontière linguistique
aujourd'hui ce sont 25 à 30 mille élèves
en alsace qui suivent un cursus bilingue
français-allemand un enseignement qui
connaît un véritable boom depuis une
quinzaine d'années ça a été une
croissance qui s'est accélérée au cours
des dix à quinze dernières années
les débuts ont été bien sûr difficile
c'était site par site et puis maintenant
je dirais qu'il ya une certaine habitude
quand même de 1,2 d'ouvrir des classes
bilingues
aujourd'hui on se heurte plutôt à des
problématiques de recrutement
d'enseignants parce que voilà le succès
fait qu'il ya un besoin croissant et
c'est ce côté là qui aujourd'hui pose
des difficultés depuis plusieurs
décennies les promoteurs de
l'enseignement bilingue ont pu compter
sur le soutien des départements alsace
et un dans le haut rhin
on mène depuis longtemps une politique
volontariste en la matière ainsi la
question du bilinguisme s'est retrouvé
au coeur du projet de collectivité
européenne d'alsace par exemple le futur
super départements alsaciens souhaite
pouvoir recruter ces enseignants qui
m'attend dans les classes donc l'idée
est vraiment de dynamiser ses politiques
et d'apprentissage de la langue
régionale dès la petite enfance en fait
surtout le parcours de l'élève
voilà pour que toutes les générations
puissent effectivement baigné dans un
nouvel environnement dialectal dans un
nouvel environnement de langues
régionales
et il ya cette question du bilinguisme
de nombreux enjeux culturels d'identité
régionale mais aussi économiques
une langue en partage des deux côtés du
rhin c'est des opportunités d'emploi et
plus des changes entre les entreprises
c'est aussi pour l'alsace la possibilité
de s'inscrire dans un espace rhénan très
dynamique
le coeur de ce projet de collectivité
européenne d'alsace la colonne
vertébrale
c'est l'europe eh bien nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui à travers la stratégie
or comme au bran bien montrer que le
bassin de vie
l'avenir de l'alsace se situe dans ce
bassin de vie qui à celui du rhin
supérieur et parler la langue ne suffit
pas encore faut-il connaître son voisin
pour rapprocher les deux rives du rhin
on souhaite également favoriser les
échanges culturels l'association alterne
compose ainsi aux jeunes alsaciens
d'effectuer leur stage de 3e en
allemagne la culture en allemagne et que
c'est quand on est jeune qu'on se
forment professionnellement et donc il
ya une capacité d'accueil d'une volonté
d'accueil qui est très forte
d'une part d'autre part de notre notre
idée notre philosophie c'est tout
simplement de dire que à 14 15 ans le
fait d'être immergé pendant toute une
semaine en autonomie dans un monde
professionnel en allemagne d'être traité
comme un autre salarié davoir
l'obligation de s'immerger
linguistiquement et culturellement dans
la vie quotidienne d'une entreprise ça
ne peut être que d'un trait banque très
grand bénéfice pour ces jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est le coup de radio m et
ne à lui loose des jeunes français et
allemands enregistrent le jingle pour
une émission qu'ils réaliseront ensemble
au parlement européen dans les
prochaines semaines radio sans
frontières un projet qui entend
rapprocher les ados de fribourg et
mulhouse autour de thématiques communes
depuis octobre trois groupes d'une
dizaine de lycéens ont réalisé cinq
on aimerait que ce soit encore plus et
ça pourrait être plus intense comme
échange là s'est il se voit trois fois
avant de pouvoir faire une émission
ensemble mais c'est déjà pas mal parce
que ça permet d'utiliser la langue de
l'autre dans un contexte qui n'est pas
scolaire de voir que c'est aussi une
langue de communication c'est une langue
pour faire ensemble allemand ça peut
servir pour faire des trucs sympas avec
avec des jeunes de l'autre côté
le projet entend créer des passerelles
entre les deux pays à ce titre il est
soutenu par le programme interreg ces
projets interreg se décline sous la
forme dans le cadre de différents
objectifs et on en compte 12 et parmi
ces douze thématiques qui ont été
déclinées on trouvera aussi bien de la
recherche que du transport que de
l'emploi la coopération entre les
administrations
et puis comme aujourd'hui et bien la
thématique qui concerne les citoyens à
partir de 2021 la collectivité
européenne d'alsace devrait disposer de
compétences étendues dans les domaines
de l'enseignement bilingue et du
transfrontalier
autant d'outils qui selon le souhait des
élus des deux départements devraient
permettre de porter plus loin de tels
projets